e
morning everybody Welcome
to the education oversight
committee and today of course we're
looking at what a wonderful way to start
with the administrative rules 30 6 and
it's been an
ongoing an ongoing parade
of having meetings and trying to address
this uh this issue so what I'd like to
do today because we've asked that we
have the commissioner president to go
through the
backside and I'd like to start off first
with the backside and and then what
we're going to do because we also have
members coming in and sitting from jel
car just observing today because they
just finished their earlier meeting
today and they're also involved with
these Ed 306 rules so with that um and
then what we're going I'm plan on doing
is that we will after we hear the
backside then we'll come around if
there's some references back to the
front side we'll deal with that and um
then following that we this committee's
tasked with making some uh
recommendations and if we look at at the
language which is
in the uh current responsibilities for
this committee and these have
changed with the addition of
legislation uh which was 1163 this this
year which went into effect September
1 uh
2024 and it reads review and make
recommendations relating to academic
standards under consideration by the
State Board of Education Pro to RSA 193
e2a Roman 4C that's in law right now and
then what was added is and the minimum
standards Public School approval under
consideration by the State Board of
Education pursuant to RSA 193 e2a Roman
4A so that went into effect um it was
approved July 3 2024 and went in effect
on September of this this last month so
with that I I'd like to go ahead and
invite the department to take us through
this
process and what we'll try to do is that
commission chair I I don't know what
that's doing it's the first time I've
seen that
chair they probably got rid of it from
another room and said we'll park it in
here um if if there's there's questions
from the committee here uh out we we
could stop and discuss something as
you're moving rather than waiting till
the end okay of your presentation so
well and we also and we also have I
asked uh Jennifer for several weeks ago
if she would to contact the department
which she did to find out which set of
uh which version is the version we're
dealing with and I believe we have that
um and what we did is we put a side by
side together for both the front and the
back and on the left hand side you'll
see what we have in education rules
right now that are currently in place
not what we did you know as far as
previous uh uh changes but going right
back to when they were approved back on
what was
it back in
2015 or so 17 wherever else but we have
that available so we'll we'll take the
side by side and look at the
backside and and uh as you go through
this uh commissioner
edbl then we can have our discussion
that sounds great and so uh thank you
for the record Frank adbl Commissioner
of Education uh Julie Shay
administrative rules coordinator for the
Department of Education thank you great
so let me just give you a little bit of
context on the backside um because we've
tried to do a great deal of research and
figure out how what the evolution of
these were where they came from how they
came about how they fit into our overall
system of um how we establish what it is
that our children in the state of New
Hampshire will be
learning um and essentially much of the
content that we saw in the backside um
from our research comes from really
pre-2000 and just to give the committee
a little bit of history about the
evolution of uh what was going on
broadly in education pre-2000 in 2001 we
got something refer to as the No Child
Left Behind Act at that time when that
was implemented nationally um there was
concern that some states not
specifically New Hampshire um were not
providing uh accurate information to
their families about how their children
were doing and what they were learning
um um and we not uh establishing
rigorous systems with high academic
standards for the children in their
learning um and so at the time there
were some stories of southern states
that uh you know there was a belief that
the rigor of the education was not what
it should be for those children and that
they were being disadvantaged so part of
the uh impulse of uh nclb or No Child
Left Behind
was a emphasis and a requirement for uh
states to implement high quality
academic standards for students so
leading up to that you did not have that
framework of you know a a framework of
high quality necessarily academic
standards that the kids were supposed to
be learning you had a variety of
different state level um you know
Frameworks that were being used much of
the content
in these content areas in the back half
again date from that pre-2000 type of a
of a um of a era uh where we had
enumerated in these back halfs our
content expectations is one way of
describing it relative to the various
areas um subsequent to that period um
the department and the state went
through a variety of uh you know very uh
comprehensive very rigorous process
cesses to develop academic standards um
and to adopt those academic standards uh
the State Board of Education starting
back in 2001 um adopted academic
standards and so the model that we
basically have in New Hampshire and
really consistent with other folks is or
other states is um you know through the
306s we're establishing the minimum
standards for
education and then in that is really
dealing with and we've done dealt with
this in the front half how do we operate
a school is the way that I like to
describe it and then in those same rules
we're trying to connect those up to
these high quality academic standards
that we have um and so essentially what
we've sort of seen is as we as a state
as we adopted these high quality
academic standards we didn't
subsequently then remove the content
areas in the back um they've for the
most part state fairly static there's
been a few tweaks here and there um but
for the most part that content stayed
static so in some respects it's almost
duplicative right because on the one
hand you have um you know adopted
highquality academic standards and on
the other hand you kept in place some of
the very content that uh you know was
which predated the highquality academic
standards um and so uh as part of our
process for kind of review doing this
back half um going back uh even all the
way back to um you know January of last
year um and this is a lot of the work
that was done uh by Christine Downing
with Educators uh she pulled together
hundreds of Educators in across content
areas and she went through the back half
and what the task was what she was uh
working towards um by agreement um and
I'll read this to you because this is uh
you know what was worked out is to take
those back half and put them into
buckets right like let's figure out
what's back there and it might be number
one that the rule language be
incorporated into another or new section
ed360 uh the proposed language for
incorporation the second bucket or
category was that rule language be
carried forward for consideration as a
modification to existing State academic
standards and content Frameworks so they
might be looking at the back half and
they say like oh you know what this
Legacy content information that we had
from pre-2000 this is still an important
thing we don't believe it's adequately
incorporated into our academic standards
and so we we think we should have like
this list of hey here's academic we
should modify our academic standard to
include these important learning
objectives for students the third
category was that rule language proposed
for Content areas not addressed by the
current academic standards and framework
so we had certain uh content areas in
the back half that did not have and I'll
enumerate those for you in a minute that
did not have state adopted academic
standards so in those cases they were
for such content areas uh their task and
the thing they were focused on was make
recommended condensed and concise
language to serve as instructional best
practices uh to be incorporated into the
3D Ed 306 rule proposal right so if I've
got an area in the back half that I
don't have an academic standard for we
still want to establish some type of
learning expectations relative to the
kids and so what would those look like
it could be the existing language or
maybe they wanted to make modifications
to it and then the final category is
like this is really just not necessary
to or it's in it's not the right place
for it to be in the Ed 306 draft so
those were the bucketed areas that um we
had asked them to uh to focus on um and
then the next thing that I want to focus
on with you and I've brought this giant
stack of paper um which really is our
academic standards our curriculum
framework right so we've got our Arts
education framework and quite I don't
know if any of you have taken a look at
these but our Frameworks are actually
quite good um they were worked on by you
know broad groups of Educators who
developed these kinds of things um and
and pulled them together uh and and
quite frankly I I'm pretty when I dug
into them and continue to read them in
in quite a lot of detail uh PR proud of
the work that the Educators did when
they pulled these things together
doesn't mean that we can't refresh them
doesn't mean that we can continue to
work on them and move them forward but
they are not uh you know just like Fly
by Night kinds of standards this was in
response to No Child Left Behind and I
think a lot of work was done in terms of
bringing this stuff forward um and what
I can tell you is that when they did the
academic standards they it was clear
that they were relying on the back half
that old the pre-2000 Legacy information
in the uh Ed 306s when they develop the
standards and sometimes what you find is
um you know they just copied straight
word for word almost sometimes it's
different right like so the Ed 306 rule
says one thing and the academic
standards that were adopted say another
thing um and so just there's an
importance of trying to make sure that
we are driving towards what we want and
I'll I'll give you some examples of
those just so that you have um an
interest or or you have an understanding
of it so for example if I'm I'm in the
uh the you know my art standards here
right and it goes through and it has you
know specific standards for dance K
through 12 curriculum Standard 1
curriculum standard 2 through 8 you know
music standards curriculum standards 1
through 10 theater standards curriculum
standards 1 through nine Visual Arts
standards curriculum standards one
through seven um and then there's in
each of these standards we actually also
have kind of an introduction it tells of
what is our learning objectives how do
you know contextualizes these academic
standards like what is the role of Arts
education in uh in our schools you know
how do quality Arts programs contribute
to the school environment how do the
Arts development workplace and you know
devel lifelong skills how do we
integrate the Arts into our other
instruction what is the purpose of the
K12 curriculum framework and for the
Arts um and so they give it some good
content before they even get to the
standards but I'll give you just an
example of kind of a conflict that sort
of comes about is if I look at my old
back half Arts education Ed 306 rule
under a you know it's like 31 a systemic
and sequential instruction in the Arts
disciplines of music and visual arts
while developing opportunities for dance
and theater where students will you know
create perform and respond but if I look
at my academic standards they don't say
that and they don't say it precisely um
they basically say that proficiency
standards specify the levels of
achievement that students are expected
to attain at the completion of grades 4
8 and 12 right so we haven't done it at
each done we did it in bands is how they
designed these art standards which I
think is a good idea you know and it
says all students should experience the
four Arts disciplines in K8 they should
have the opportunity to acquire
Knowledge and Skills identified in the
KA proficiency standards and then it
says typically students in grades 9
through 12 elect to focus on one of the
Arts disciplines so right there you can
see a conflict between what was in the
old or the Legacy Arts stand standards
and when that information was brought
forward and the team that worked on the
Arts education standards they said okay
uh you know we are going to you know
Focus uh you know on in K8 about across
all of these various Arts disciplines
but then when we get to high school it's
okay if the students you know Target and
focus but that's inconsistent
necessarily with what was in the 8306
rule I mean another example of it is uh
you know we talk about in Ed 306 rule
the first line talks about creating
performing and responding with
understanding and what's interesting
when I go to my academic standards it
uses those same three ideas but it puts
a little context around them and it
talks about creating original works of
art performing new or existing works of
arts and responding to the artworks and
performance uh performances of self and
others so it gives you a little bit more
context about how the Educators might
use that um and I could take you through
and if you're interested I can take you
other standards as well but it's this
just imagine it's the same kind of you
know sometimes they align sometimes they
don't align sometimes one some one's
more specific um but what I want to make
sure is that we know that for our
students in their art education we want
the Educators focused on the academic
standards for Arts education right like
this is what we want our kids to know
we've defined it very clearly um you
know in terms of what it is that that
students should be able to attain um and
what we don't want and I think would be
a mistake is if we confuse our education
system in the uh ed360 is and we
basically put some what I will refer to
as kind of pseudo standards in the back
half of the 306 and but then we also
offer this what we don't want is we
don't want Educators going to the 306s
and thinking if they've met this 30 Ed
306 requirement that they are not that
they've somehow met their obligation
because it it is not as rigorous not as
comprehensive not as descriptive as the
actual standards themselves so with that
in mind this is this kind of outlines
our approach for how we uh took on the
back half and I will start with Arts
education but then I'm going to just
lean in on a couple of more things while
we while we're talking Arts um when I
looked at the front side yep there was a
section which dealt with uh let see at
30621 that's the kindergarten through
grade 8 school curriculum M then when I
weigh down through that I come to a
section which is dealing with Arts
education including music and visual
arts where we had in the old 306s while
developing opportunities in dance and
theater so you have the dance and
theater out and I believe that folks
have used the backside as a place to
search for academic standards seeing
that we had curriculum Frameworks we got
rid of them for a while we introduced
them back this year and said those
curriculum Frameworks are aligned with
academic standards and and based upon
those academic standards so you can what
I I said I I think people have been
confused well this is what we're trying
to tangle that that's what I'm concerned
about and let me I'm going to continue
to explain that and let me tell you how
I think we've broken through that
confusion um if I may so like so hold
hold that thought for one second um
representative so if I go over to the
final proposal right so if I take ed30
6.27 in the um the final proposal right
if you look under Arts education you
know under a it basically says the local
school board shall ensure a
developmentally appropriate Arts
education program for each School
consistent with local competencies and
curriculum pursuant to Ed 30621 to 22
okay so there's your reference to the
front half where we've enumerated we've
said you have to have an Arts education
program and then B each school's Arts
education program shall have competence
in curriculum aligned to the K12
curriculum framework Arts that's what
this academic standards is that was the
the exact title off of it dated April 21
as referenced in appendix 2 so we are
incorporating these by reference saying
you have to offer an arts program as
we've enumerated in the front half and
that arts program has to meet these
academic standards that we got and then
finally we have school district shall
adhere to the assessment practices of Ed
30619 so in the areas where we've got
academic standards what we're trying to
do with these rules is incorporate by
reference all of these academic
standards so that you know an educator
reading this is they like oh okay so my
arts program or a superintendent or
curriculum person is going to read this
and say like great I'm supposed to offer
an Arts education program that looks
like this um and so that's what we've
tried to simplify these rules to help
focus on that um you know that's that
was kind of the approach that we've
taken so Frank commissioner yeah that's
Frank is good too Frank's good um the
curriculum Frameworks which we've had in
the past have served as a guide as it's
stated was stated in law and we took
that out and now we're saying that the
curriculum Frameworks are our academic
standards so I think that going back and
again this has happened way this is go
this one's going back to 2001 that the
if you look at the history people have
used academic standards and curriculum
Frameworks synonymously right they have
not distinguished so if I look at the
K12 curriculum framework for the Arts
dated April 2021 it says standard one
standard two standard three so we have
established in these Frameworks the
academic standards that we expect
students to meet so for example dance
curriculum standard number one identify
and demonstrate movement elements and
skills of performance dance is the first
standard if I and then the thing that's
valuable is that you don't just leave it
at that kind of short sentence in these
curriculum Frameworks then if you go
over to like I've got an entire page
that describes what that means right so
Educators have a lot of guidance and it
says at so if the first one the
curriculum standard says Identify and
demonstrate movement and elements of
skill in performance dance so that then
it says proficiency standards at the end
of grade four students will be able to
demonstrate axial movements demonstrate
the eight basic locate loc motor
movements of walk run hop jump skip Le
like so we've we've given them a lot
more meat about what it is that we have
an expectation but the idea of
Frameworks being only guides doesn't
seem like like the these things over the
years got different titles some got
called Frameworks I got my health
education curriculum guidelines which
then enumerate all of the academic
standards for health education and what
it is that we expect these kids to know
do they all say academic standards they
all establish they use different
vernacular in the titles but they all
establish the standards of what we
expect kids to know at the various
levels so all of them use the vernacular
about standards is that so stated at the
front of each one of these I I've looked
at them yeah and I got them all here too
I get copies yes yeah um so I mean again
this one Health is you know health
education curriculum guidelines but if
you go three p health education
standards and assessment right so they
all drive towards that I think the idea
of the framework is sometimes you have
more so for example in this Arts we've
got a lot of introduction in here right
because it talks about again what is the
role of arts and education you know how
do quality Arts programs contribute to
the environment how do they develop what
lifelong uh you know workplace skills
you know how do you integrate the art so
I think that I don't again I wasn't
around in the in the time frame when
these were developed but the idea of
framework was to say like well don't
just tell them these like a common core
these are all the academic standards as
much as put some context about why we're
doing this instruction and stuff like
that but again it wasn't there so I'm
speculating as to what the thought
process might be but you can see what
we're creating here is a system for the
schools for the Educators that very
tightly says you got to have the arts
program and here's what our expect
ations are with respect to that art
program and not
incorporate uh you know other stuff
which may or may not be gerain to what
it is we expect or it may send a
conflicting message like we know that
there are conflicts between what's in
the back in the old back half and what's
in the curriculum Frameworks and or the
curriculum standards however you want to
whatever vernacular you want to use and
so what we think we're doing with this
this this model that we're giving to
everybody and and quite frankly I don't
I'm not sure how it would be
controversial because we're really just
clarifying the the the academic
standards role in this whole process um
and and so if I might then I want to
talk about a a couple of the areas that
didn't have like these are academic
standards right and I got academic
standards for many of my areas but I
have some that I don't right as an
example I've got a business education
program and I don't have I think that
actually representative luno might want
to asked me a question so just just a
quick question thank you very much Mr
commissioner yeah um and and I and I I I
really appreciate the explanation that
you that you've given us this morning
because I think it does help um help me
understand what um what obviously what
uh what the department has been trying
to do and
also uh I get I guess get a little bit
better handle on um on some of the
terminology that you're using for
example you were just referring to you
were just holding up curriculum
Frameworks right those are the that is
that the stack of um things so well I
mean some they have different titles
they call they're called guidelines but
if you look on our website they were all
adopted by the State Board of Education
as academic standards so so so we we we
use these am I right then that we're
using these terms um interchangeably
curriculum Frameworks academics
standards so what I'm using when I refer
to these documents I refer to them as
academic standards although they have
different titles because that's I'm not
worried about the title I'm worried
about functionally white so functionally
that's the way that the State Board of
Education has acted on them okay
historically no that that helps me a lot
and and then just picking on the arts
program because it's on the first you
know the first part of the sheet um
there's a lot that you explained that is
in the existing rule
30631 that you know sort of gets down
analyze and evaluate uh recognize
exemplary works all that stuff is
essentially at least my understanding of
what I think I heard you say is being
replaced by in the new rule 27 B this
reference to the curriculum framework
for the Arts April 2001 edition that's
correct okay so all this stuff which
used to be in in
31 is now is now that so and so and the
reason just to reiterate kind of the
reason why that the Legacy stuff that
you had in the old Ed 306 Arts education
was like a for the most part there have
been some edits over the years but for
the most part was content that was pre
uh No Child Left Behind which didn't
have the framework of high quality
academic standards across these domain
areas right so so I'm trying to get get
get a sense as to what what uh what
we're what we're looking at here so so
uh What uh what's what's being proposed
here is to
replace sort of a page and a half of
language from rule 31
30631 with with what you just held up
there which clearly has a lot more to it
than than rule 31 so so let me just
clarify because when you say that we're
replacing it like this always existed
right so it's not replacing that what
we're concerned about is that that that
old language in the Arts education might
be confused by some people to be a
faximile of this and it is a what I
would refer to as a poor and sometimes
inconsistent fa simile of this no no and
I and and I I hear what you're saying on
that commissioner U but in fact it is
replacing it because it's
deleting the the the you know everything
in 31 that sort of defines that content
or that academic standard um from the
you know you've used other terms content
areas contact expectations it's removing
it from that and in the new rule 27 B
each School's art education program
shall have competencies and curriculums
aligned to K12 curriculum framework for
the Arts um April 2001 edition as
referenced in appendix 2 cor so so so
where where that curriculum framework
was previously not Tethered to the to
the minimum standards for school
approval it is now connected to the it
is now tethered and and part of the
requirements so what I I would clarify
that it was always required right so
that the school districts under the old
306 whether that is that in the front
half were required to offer a uh
academic program that aligned to the
academic standards that have been
adopted by the State Board of Education
so simply so so nothing it's always been
tethered it's not it's not a new
tethering it's what it is it's a clearer
tethering right because if I were to go
through some of the front half we you
know even in the old old front half of
the 306s as well as the current half you
know you're required to uh offer courses
that align you're required to develop
competencies that align to the state
adopted academic standards like we've
always said that but the problem is it
was opaque and I don't think people were
it it allowed people to as easily make
the interconnect of what it is we're
asking them to do this makes it very
clear what our expectations are for what
the children should be learning in
school and and and and you so you you
won't be confused and somehow think that
because you looked at the back half
you've met this requirement because you
didn't look at another section of the
rules someplace right so now we've made
those connections in the content areas
themselves which I think is a clearer
way to communicate to our school leaders
okay no I I appreciate so making those
connections in the content areas that's
that's why we're referring to the back
half as academic standards no we're not
referring to them as academic standards
these are basically the areas of
instruction that individuals are
required to um you know offer and we're
telling them what the criteria is for
offering that right so in the front half
we enumerate your required offer and our
in in 30621 and 30622 we require you to
offer an Arts education program and we
are saying that that program shall have
competencies in curriculum aligned to
this document as it as has always been
the uh you know the requirement but now
it's clear what it is that you're trying
to do right
so uh represent edible then represent
Cordell here uh this year we passed uh
HB
1107 this is a bill dealt with the
curriculum Frameworks one in ufx
September 10th 2024 so it's not yet on
probably online we won't see it but it's
there and it says curriculum framework
means an organized plan of study that
serves as a guide and reference to what
New Hampshire student should know and be
able to do in a learning area and
identifies the academic standards
aligned with learning area learning area
pursuant to RSA 193
e2a uh Roman
1A so is this
clarifying what you're trying you're
doing as the department that this new
statutory language which was placed put
back into law is this doing is it is is
it stated properly it says area and
identifies the ACT academic standards
um so can I just answer Julie wants to
answer in this but let me just waigh in
so as I understood that law I thought
that you were pushing out so for example
I would say that my current uh you know
K12 curriculum Frameworks for the Arts
which includes the academic standards as
that law requires also does the first
half of that definition of pushing out
and describing the context for how that
would be applied and stuff like that but
I will also say that so I have my nextg
science standards right and my nextg
science standards they don't include
they don't incorporate as much of that
contextual information so these might
potentially be
more correctly identified as academic
standards not in a curriculum framework
so then this would be one that would
require that c curriculum framework
envelope around it um I think that many
of and and perhaps even most of my other
academic standards do have much of the
framework language framework envelope
around them already you know as an
example like so we we pointed out like
my health curriculum has you know a lot
of introductory materials about the how
the why the context but then it also
specifically defines the academic
standard so as I understood the
definition that you wrote you read there
um you're basically the framework
element of It kind of and again I don't
know what they understood back then
right but that it wraps an envelope
around those academic standards to
provide them context and I think that uh
most of our currently adopted academic
standards would probably meet the
definition of framework some should be
looked at so when we last identifi at
the last framework which would B
basically the National Science standards
I think that's the most recent yeah
that's the one I was pointing to that's
the one you're just pointing to and so
do we have to then rework the science
curriculum Frameworks to say that and to
incorporate those national standards
into that framework do we have a job in
front of us to update some of these
standards such as the social studies
which is done back in 2006 yeah so I
mean what I can tell you is that I I
would frame it a little bit differently
I think we have good science academic
standards what we would need to do to
comply with that law is wrap them in the
framework of context for uh the
instruction but that you do have
standards and again all of these have
been adopted by the State Board of
Education as academic standards the fact
that they you know for example in arts
the fact that it also when they adopted
it it included the framework wrapping
around it didn't you know diminish the
fact that it directly Incorporated the
academic standard expectations that we
have for our children represent cordelli
and and then at some point I want to
Pivot to because because we haven't
touched on all the areas so okay uh
thank you for being here both of you um
I I think this is helpful for me because
we faced some of this with legislation
this past year we had uh several bills
related to health and mental health and
we were looking at both the rules and
then the health education CRI curriculum
guidelines from 2003 and saying well
which you know which is which you know
what what are we going by and we talked
about the curriculum guidelines from
2003 looked quite comprehensive uh to us
and I can see where there was the the
framework around the standards um so I I
think that this will help uh
staff um understand you know what is
expected of them and the students and um
my only analogy would be with parents
and the confusion they have with special
education where we have federal law
state law and then rules that
and go Way Beyond both so you know it's
hard for parents to understand what to
look at and so I think if you know we
can help staff to understand where the
direction is and also help parents
understand the direction of uh where
things should be going uh I think will
uh uh definitely improve uh education
for the students so I mean I I do think
that this is a more it's a clearer way
to communicate right right like so
essentially we're not changing anything
so much as setting up the system so it's
understandable and everybody recognizes
you know what their obligations how
they're supposed to go about doing this
um and bear in mind that we have you
know from the work that Christine Downey
done you know one of our bullets was
that is there something in here you know
in these old back halfs that we need to
bring forward and look at the academic
standards I mean I can tell you one of
the areas I I I hesitate to bring it up
because um
like I'm not making a proposal but I
mean I think that there was some years
there is a degree of agreement among
many of our Educators even if I just
look at my common core standards have
not Incorporated a lot of the science of
reading developments that we've seen so
um you know is it possible then we need
to be revisiting those but the idea of
opening up Common Core just sort of
scares me
so um but I mean but so like so they've
identified these things that were saying
like yeah we got to keep working we need
to continue working forward on our
standards but now we have a Model A
framework sorry for using that
vernacular twice here but whereby as a
state it's clear what our expectations
are how we're going forward what we're
working on um but if I may let me just
identify because if you recall in the
work that Christine was doing and in our
work on this there are some of these
areas in the back half that we didn't
have academic standards for so I just
want to walk you through what those are
and essentially what we have done uh
with respect to those so the first area
is business education right so we do not
have business education academic
standards that have been adopted by the
State Board of Education what we have
Incorporated are two elements that we
think are important um in our CTE world
so our Career and Technical education
programming there's a lot of business
education programs uh those business
education programs have adopted
competencies um and those the adoption
of those competencies follows a process
that includes uh you know the
stakeholder inut from the CTE programs
as well as the industry advisory boards
and they have adopted those so uh we
have brought those forward to
incorporate into the business education
program and that's the language that you
see in front of you there to try and uh
allow that to be incorporated so uh
Frank yep when I look at
1932a yeah the substance education CR
business is not there correct um so are
the academic standards as later on
talked in Roman four of that um H do
they are these academic standards for
the substant areas of an adequate
education or are we now extending Beyond
you know for example yeah there's
nothing in in the Frameworks about
personal finance literacy and that is in
our but that is incorporated into the
business though I have Incorporated
personal financial literacy into this
but you're renaming economics or what as
business because it's it's not there as
a part of our adequate education correct
I mean and this is a a conversation that
I don't even if jart wants to address it
you know because you'll recall we had
this conversation in the front half
remember there was the list of
instructional areas um that we included
and you know because we had it in the
past we did carry forward and you know
we've gone back and forth of including
not including uh you know there was we
had family and consumer science and we
had business education neither of which
were enumerated in 193
e2a um you know you'll notice that the
family and consumer science is not
incorporated into this because there was
a belief that that would be embedded in
the other areas um business education
was there if if uh you know when this
thing is in front of jel car if jel car
wants us to remove the idea of business
education we're happy to do that um you
know but we want to make sure that we're
clear about uh you know so so I don't
disagree that there is this what is a
parent conflict that exists
so yes rep s luno thanks very much Mr
chair so um I I want to go back to um to
what Arts yeah just just just because
it's right at the right at the front and
I think it's probably a good example to
uh to to drill into okay um because
we've been talking about it but um but I
took a look at the uh again at the at
the front half rules and uh where the
existing rules and I'm looking at
existing rule
26 which is K8 so new proposed Rule 21
um rep would would propose to replace it
but exist existing rule
20 do I have it right
26 uh well 21 is K kindergarten through
8th grade school ccul yeah yeah but the
existing rule number is 26 okay yeah and
30631 which is on the front page of the
of the back half with respect to
relative to an Arts education and um and
so I'm I'm trying to find out where in
the minimum the minimum standards for
school
approval where where either where any of
these 306 rules um refer to the uh the
Frameworks the academic standards
whatever you want
to I just I couldn't find it so that's
okay I'll have I'll find it for you just
one
very I'm reading on page 21 School
District shall adop District based on
State academic standards where for all
coures of study school districts may use
State model competencies to develop
distri compes all right so um so this is
right I don't know I I think I'm looking
this is I'm I'm looking out a document
proposal
reest not it I don't yeah yeah yeah yeah
I I actually I see I there's another one
that says um conditional approval
request and it's got your your
letterhead on the the front so page 21
on
U okay and is that is that in current
rule that's in this
proposal
place so what what what I'm really
trying to get that is is is you you
know we're talking about how the
curriculum Frameworks here I think I use
the term are going to replace what's
what's in rule 31 right now so the Arts
framework replac no no no and that's and
that's fine um and and and I said well
the framework I think I asked whether
the framework had been Tethered to the
existing rules and you said they are um
and so I'm just trying to determine
where the where where they are because
if they are part of if they are Tethered
to the existing rules then they then the
Frameworks are in fact a requirement for
minimum you know minimum requirement for
school approval if they're not connected
then they're not a requirement and in
fact what would be the requirement is
what's in
30631 the part that's being removed and
so what I'm what I'm respectfully
suggesting is that if what's being
removed which talks a lot about what
goes into an Arts you know curriculum
and maybe and may be confusing given the
comprehensive I know and having not seen
that I I but you know you can just look
at the size of the binder clip you've
got there um I I would agree with it but
in fact that if if if that wasn't
already a requirement and is now
becoming a requirement than it is in
fact a change to academic requirements
the because now we're saying that that
one thing that that used to be an
academic requirement in 31 is now
being connected to something else
instead um so the way that I would
respond to that and I'm not prepared
today to to create that teing to the old
rule because I just haven't looked it up
and it obviously it's very complicated
um I don't think that there's anyone in
the education environment today
who would not say that this is our
expectation for what children should be
learning in um you know School my
curriculum and instruction folks are
very familiar and you're I mean even
just take math and science or math and
uh and English and my common core
standards like everybody um certainly
understands like like I would be
hesitant it almost sounds like the
argument that you're making up right now
is that somehow Common Core math and
Common Core English are not required in
the schools um and I think that that and
I'm I'd have to go back and figure out
where that Nexus is drawn specifically
but I believe that it is probably quite
clearly drawn uh some you know in in a
variety places maybe not as clearly as
it could have which is why we're trying
to clarify things here but I don't think
anybody's arguing that those things are
not what our expectations are for
children yeah no I I I I hear what
you're saying on that but but I think if
if we if we are going to be be you know
referring to the the Frameworks the
academic standards in the new rules
we're incorporating them by reference
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah that's
referring to themp incorporating them by
reference then um then we should know
what those uh what those new AC what
those academic standards that are now
being referred um and now being
incorporated into the rules by reference
we should understand what they are we
should understand um whether or not um
schools are already in compliance with
those standards particularly if they're
if they're not currently required under
rules and we got to we got to sort that
out we haven't been able to find that
that reference yet so so I so I guess
the only thing and Julie wants to jump
in I can tell and and I I guess the
third point I would want to know too on
him is is that uh in fact our our
curriculum Frameworks that were
developed in 2001 are those still
considered by by um by Arts uh teachers
to be um to be you know uh relevant and
um and up to date I guess I mean I don't
have the answers today so these are the
academic standards so okay you go ahead
Sor um all right so in in this back half
if you look at each of the sections um
we have tethered each piece back to
those sections they're not numbered in
the same way as what you were just
referring to because these are the new
numbers so in a for Arts education
you'll see it says 21 22 yeah sorry what
yes so um which was formerly 26 and 27
exactly so each so you know it's saying
the appropriate Arts education program
for each School contestant with local
competencies and curriculum pursuant to
30621 and 30622 which is the K through 8
section and then the high school section
so um it is kind of tying those um
requirements back to those sections in
each area rather than but but in in in
306 um
21 looking at the K8 section uh on page
42 of the side by side that we got so
I'm
not the only the only
reference to to Arts education in in K8
306 proposed rule number
21 is a Arts education including music
and visual arts that's all it says so
you're looking for a citation 2 30626 or
whatever it is to tie those two sections
together no I mean I think um 30
30627 the new the new Arts refers to
30621 but but but the only thing 30621
says for Elementary grades 1 through
eight where no middle school has been
established by vote of the local school
board um local Schoolboard shall um you
know you compens in the following areas
and the only part related to Arts says
Arts education including music and
visual arts that's all it says that's
all 21 says so so but the way that the
framework works is then we enumerate
what is an Arts education and now when
we enumerate what is in arts education
this is what an Arts education is right
so there's no that's in part in
paragraph B correct 27 so when so when
you reach that place it says Arts
education you're going this is what our
expectations are for your art education
program right so the qu the question is
is that the current because the the
current standard for Arts education is
the part that was cut out of of of the
old 3063 I don't I don't know that
that's the case well I mean it's
different than what you're holding up
because this is only a page and a half
and that's got a half inch binder clip
on it when we so everything that was in
that in the current
rule a lot of it was duplicative of
what's already in those standards and so
by incorporating that document by
reference that is making that entire
document the rule but it's far too long
to list no no I'm not I I I I'm fully on
board with incorporating by reference I
mean my background is engineering
everything's Incorporated by reference
on that or else you know any spec would
be a gazillion pages long so but but
representative luno I don't think
anybody is under the misconception like
you're you're framing the conversation
as if that back half was the academic
standard and I don't think that that is
um our understanding of what that is our
understanding is that that is a rule uh
that predated for the most part 2000
that included something prior to the
State Board of Education actually
adopting the framework and academic
standards and as a result of that this
is our academic standard when the State
Board of Education adopted you know
Common Core math and Comm core English
the schools did not then when they were
teaching math instruction ref only to
the back half they knew that they were
developing and implementing curriculum
that align to those Common Core academic
standards there was no confusion that a
school district said like well we're
going to ignore those standards and
we're only going to do the stuff that's
in the back
half so I don't think that so your
characterization of those of that back
half being the academic standards that
was uh not the case because the State
Board of Education had adopted academic
stands across these areas except for the
ones that I'm going to take you through
that we didn't adopt no no fair fair
enough I just don't see any reference in
the existing 306 rules any reference to
those um academic standards the
curriculum framework correct and I'm
happy to go back and I'll Define the NEX
I'll I'll develop that connection for
you and um or and because essentially
what I think you're the the uh the frame
that you're setting up is that uh for
the last 20 years schools have been
complying with these academic standards
that that have been set as the
expectation and that you're I I I'm I'm
a little bit concerned about your uh
your line of argumentation because
you're saying and schools didn't have to
comply with any of that stuff for the
last 20 years I just I just want to know
if they if they had to or not given the
minimum standards not I believe not yeah
I I I I I think it's good to have to
have compliance with rigorous academic
standards I'm all in favor of that but
but if it wasn't there before then it's
a change to academic St standards which
I think this so so it wouldn't is about
and
and want to see what I just want to
clarify something because it's not a
change to academic standards we have not
changed these academic standards again
when you characterize that back half as
the academic standards then you may
assume that it's a chang to academic
standards these are the academic
standards we are not changing academic
standards and and even to your point
like like I'm trying to be constructive
in terms of how do we go forward like
even like I'm going to go back and I'll
try and create this Nexus so you can see
how this stuff was working but either
way moving forward we've now created a
system that has Clarity that is clear in
terms of this is how you operate a
school these are expectations for kids
learning everybody's on the same page
we've eliminated the risk associated
with uh you know those um somebody
incorrectly understanding what the
expectation was for the children and I
think the way that you're characterizing
it is not
um I've never experienced uh well I'm
just not sure it's a it's a good
characterization yeah all I'm all I'm
saying is is I want to see the link
between the existing 306 rules and what
you're what you're referring to as the
academic standards I want to understand
what that connection is what where that
requirement you know exists under
current uh 306 rules and U that that
would I think help uh help me out a lot
okay thank I think there's confusion
as a result of what the legislature did
going back probably about nine years ago
when we dumped the curriculum
Frameworks and so then folks were
looking and saying what is health and so
we went to the 306 Sy and oh it list
mental health and emotional this and
that in there that I think was the
Assumption of where the academic
standards were
located um and and since then we
realized through the legislative action
we took this last session that we the
curriculum Frameworks are the the the
documents which are aligned with the
academic standards and contain the
academic
standards and and so I've asked the
question over and over and over again to
probably yourself rank as one where are
the academic standards what are the
academic standards and and you've always
responded to me curriculum Frameworks I
said we don't have curriculum Frameworks
we dump those and so then people because
we dumped them saying okay now we're
going to go to 306s that's where we're
seeing the the the statement that
represent cordelli mentioned when we had
that confusion this year mental Health's
listed there as some of those content
areas
within you're referencing within Health
um so I I think it's partially our fault
for what's going on and I think we need
to get back to have some clarity as
exactly what are the academic standards
and where they're located I think we've
done that um or in the process of trying
to get there and that's really what
we're trying to do is just create a
cohesive system that's understandable
and clear for everybody so that you
don't have to ask questions like well
where are these things tethered right
are they tethered are they not tethered
are does common core standard just float
out and in some ether sphere that we
don't have to comply with is kind of
your implication and I'm like uh you
know this system as we've kind of laid
it out is basically just creating a
follow you have any else so the I mean
I'll just so I'll just hit the other
areas so we talked about business Ed uh
we talked about so School counseling was
one of the areas that was in the back
half um that we don't have academic
standards for and truthly it's a little
bit out of place but um in terms of
being there but we just pretty much you
know whe than tuning up the language we
basically kept that program um you know
kept much of that language other than
try to just make it more concise and
precise um digital literacy was one uh
the language that we got into the back
half for digital literacy was the
language that we had in the front half
for graduation requirements with respect
to digital literacy so that those are
consistent and again aiming for
consistency and then the last area was
something called Tech engineering and um
again there don't have engineering
academic standards that have been
adopted so so we incorporated into this
back half the uh competencies that are
used in the Career and Technical
education engineering programs and so
those are the four areas is there one
more okay I just wanted to just point
out in case anybody um was looking at it
that um the last section Holocaust and
genocide curriculum was repealed it is
not taken away we added it to social
studies uh because it is a section of
social studies and it's supposed to be
integrated into social studies so again
for consistency rather than it being its
own section
we didn't change any of the language we
just moved it over to social
studies thank you and and yes we have
these 13 areas that you're referencing
right here 193
e2a and or 11 um 11 areas but then we
have 12 and 13 which are not areas of
substance criteria for inadequate
education computer and digital
literacy and logic and rhetoric thinking
and
communicating um we expect the intent
when that this was done was that those
areas would be incorporated and embedded
into all those 11 other primary areas of
learning which are part of the
opportunity for an adequate
education so when we're starting now to
write out academic standards
for digital literacy so so we've not
created academic standard for digital
literacy the department doesn't even
have the authority to do that that
belongs to the State Board of Education
so all that we've provided I mean
similar to you know the request that we
made going back to January last year
right that um you know basically rule
language to to look at this back
language is there kind of best practi
are there things that we need to be
focused on so we've not made an attempt
to establish uh academic standards in
these areas we are basically providing
some guidelines because otherwise there'
be nothing in there at all and again we
didn't have academic standards where we
had academic standards I'm incorporating
in my reference where we don't have
academic standards we've tried to keep
that language or use language that's
already in existence and is being
leveraged by
individuals and Career Technical
education is in another one of these
areas which is not identified here 193e
however it is a program of study a
coures and program of study that leading
to Career Pathways and you'll see there
used in the old version there was CTE
language in the back half that we've
incorporated into the front half because
part of this exercise was if there's
something in the back half that properly
belongs in the front half we've moved it
up to the front half because that's
where it belongs because that was the
content of what we were looking at so Mr
chair yes um thank you Mr chair and and
commissioner so um you were just talking
about the uh the business education
program and um and so this is
formerly the old the existing rule 30633
is being replaced with or being proposed
to be replaced with proposed Rule
30628 and um and you'd mentioned that in
the business education program you do
not have an academic standard in that
pile there for business education that's
correct so um so uh What uh what's being
done in in uh in proposed rule
30628 is um is
replacing you know things like you know
accredit and business technology
application s accompass business
technology and work processing
spreadsheet development database
management presentations and on and on
with um with uh with things like um like
uh earning income including
understanding career paths and potential
compensation for career path stuff like
that you're saying those aren't academic
standards correct these are not academic
standards all right so so while in the
arts
program you you eliminated all the stuff
that was in there and replaced it with a
reference to an academic standard
because you don't have an academic
standard you couldn't do that in the in
the business curriculum um but what you
replace it with you're saying is not an
academic standard right so I mean the
process for academic standards those
have to go through the State Board of
Education these have not gone through
the State Board of Education with
respect to yeah not as academic
standards so we're not proposing
academic standards here because we okay
so just to be clear just because you
don't call them academic standards then
they're not academic standards is that
my understanding well there's a process
for how something becomes an academic
standards and these have not gone
through the process of becoming academic
standards so uh we don't believe that
they are but we also because we didn't
have anything to make an incorporation
by reference doc reference to right um
and we didn't want to just eliminate any
guidance for our Educators with respect
to business education we didn't want to
just like leave them in the alerts like
sorry there's not an academic standard
for business education we don't want to
leave you out on your alert so what we
did is we've incorporated into this uh
you know other content that we think is
germine uh you know for them and and
useful for them so sure but but in law
it says academic standards means what a
student should know and be able to do in
a course or at each grade level yeah and
so is isn't that what you know spending
including budgeting consumer decision
making federal and state consumer
protection laws uh you know AR aren't
these academic standards as at least
defined by maybe maybe not as defined by
the State Board of Ed but defined by
Statute uh no I I would 100% not agree
with that I mean in other words we're
basically just outlining areas of a
business education program for our
schools like if you're going to do it
but it's not we're not as opposed to the
difference is if I go to an academic
standard over in my Arts education right
and so curriculum standard number two
identify choreographic principles in
grade four students will be able to
create a sequence with a beginning
middle and end both with and without a
rhythmic accompaniment and identify each
part of the sequence improvise create
perform movements based on their own
ideas and ideas from other sources uh
use improvision to discover like in
other words like academic St are much
more uh specific to what and that was
for fourth grade and then I've got them
for eighth grade and so on these are not
these are uh you know a list of again uh
borrowed from our CTE programming of
Competency areas for these students in a
business program but I don't have
academic standards and I know that you
keep wanting to tether this somehow to
standards I'm not sure we're trying to
create a system that is supportive of
our schools uh in terms of what they're
trying to do no I'm not I'm not saying
what uh what I want to to do I'm trying
to figure out what you're trying to do
here and when it comes to um academic
standards if academic standards are
being changed because um they were not
connected with the minimum standards for
school approval in the past but are
being proposed to be uh to be
incorporated then then I consider that
to be a change by requiring uh academic
standards to be uh to be part of the um
the 306 rules where they have it in the
past that's all I'm I'm I'm not taking
uh taking a position on the content I'm
process okay I'd like to just tag in a
little bit on this conversation we're
having on the on the the business side
of things here uh within that uh area of
30628 you have an item down
below uh that states it's a c under five
um
yeah it's hard to see the read each
district shall establish and provide
competencies and curriculum for personal
finance literacy that includes the
following content
areas Now personal finance literacy has
been recently placed in as a criteria
within
adequacy and it was put forth by the New
Hampshire Bankers Association and large
groups and signed in a law um and we
also say the personal finance literacy
uh skills may be embedded in exi an
existing course or grade level program
of
studies so this is being treated it's a
it's a a criteria that's a part of
adequacy but we're saying you might be
able to embed this in rather
than I'm I'm trying to see okay where
are the standards for personal finance
literacy we don't have them developed
yet do we we do not we have not adopted
personal financial litery so now what
you're doing is putting some content
areas Within personal finance literacy
into
rule so we're basically putting some
areas of of personal financial literacy
into Rule and I think the expectation
would be that as we adopt a personal
financial literacy academic standard
that this rule would then be subsided by
you know you take this out of here and
move it over to there but today I don't
have that and I don't want to leave
schools with no guidance at all so are
rules saying that within rule are they
saying that you have to take a course in
personal finance Literacy for graduation
if you go to when in fact we're saying
you don't have to it must be embedded in
another course the skills and
knowledge so we enumerate if you go back
to the front half schools are required
if I go to probably 22 I'm going to
guess is it what it
is or
yeah if you go to page
22 uh it lists the course offerings that
uh school districts are required to have
the local Schoolboard shall require a
program of studies with learning
opportunities offered to high school
students in the following areas um and
literacy it's on page 22 of the uh
conditional approval
request conditional we have not
commented on whether that is integrated
or not integrated we're just saying that
the students in this rule students are
required
to a program of studies with learning
opportunities offered in personal
financial
literacy on page on the conditional
approval process I'm looking at page 29
okay so these are the credit
requirements for graduation you're
saying now that on personal fin on
finance literacy you have to have one
one half credit but you have to earn the
credit but it doesn't mean that you
can't earn that credit in an integrated
class or something else like that right
so we're notating to do it a dual credit
or a concurrent credit other words you
might be taking it in the form of an
economics
class and you earn a half a credit
economics and a half also going to get a
half credit if you take that half credit
economics class or you're going to get a
half credit for finance literacy at the
same time again that would be up to our
local school districts to design you
know course structures the way that they
intend them to be incorporated um so
that that's I they could do it as an
individual class they could do it as a
integrated class and and quite frankly
that happens even today and we think
that integrated education is a great
thing um I have schools that offer
social studies and Ela classes together
um you know to allow students to
integrate some of their subjects as
well and so integration is not a I'm a
fan of integration so those occurrences
approved by the department no those
areer instead of this economics class is
not going to be giving out total of one
credit rather than a half credit well I
don't know how many credits they'll give
out it would be depend on how they
structure that class if they structure a
half a credit of economics and a half a
credit of personal financial literacy
then yes it would be a a one credit
class but it really is up to the local
school districts and how they want to
configure those classes in the way that
they think it's best for those students
education but at the end of the day to
your point on page 29 in order to
graduate from to receive a diploma from
a New Hampshire uh um you know School uh
you're required to have where's my
personal financial you have to pass the
financial literacy you have to have
financial
literacy but what happens to the school
board saying well we embedded that
personal Finance literacy and some other
subject here which we're allowed to do
by Statute yep so they're allowed to
embed it I mean if the if the
legislature wants to change that law and
say that it shouldn't be embedded it has
to be a standalone course then I'm sure
we will all adapt to that as well that's
a financial issue it's a it's a
determination from this legislature in
terms of whether they want I mean again
if the statute today allows it to be
integrated it can be integrated I don't
know that that's a bad thing uh like I I
don't I don't immediately integration I
don't I don't see as as negative um and
I don't want to imply that because it's
subpar further questions on the back
half
here okay there are no more questions on
the back
half there are questions I know we have
in the first half okay I I will do my
best I was not did not come prepared to
address the first
now the back half that has been approved
by the State Board of Education the back
half has been approved by the state and
the front half as well and the front
half as
well and neither of those has
been given any kind of a uh
consideration or well not they've been
given consideration but approval by Jael
car so we've had a preliminary hearing
at Jael car and we've been asked to come
back in
November with both of them together they
wanted to see them all together
okay but we also wanted to have an
opportunity to meet with you all are you
willing to Wade through us with us the
first part a little bit here I I'll do
my best I just um you know I may uh
defer if I don't have an answer for you
there
M um Mr chair yes yeah just a um maybe
maybe an area that we could look at on
the back half if if that's what the
commissioner is more prepared for but um
I think we talked about it briefly the
CTE well well let's let's that's later
on let no no that's let's take some of
the definitions here first I I would
like to discuss the definition of
educator okay and the educator what you
have here
in uh under
definitions I don't have page numbers
this is I can address it it's not page
to and I I will point out um you know
representative that uh when we brought
this to jeler was pointed out to us we
did not know that there was a statutory
definition of educator in 21n because we
were searching through the education
laws not the 21n laws um so we expect
that the definition of educator will be
homogenized with the with the statutory
definition because I mean I think I
shared this with you all before our goal
is to uh make sure that this has as
tight of compliance with the statutes as
possible okay why I'm going
there I'm looking at that right now so
educator means administrators education
Specialists instructional Specialists
teachers par par Educators educational
interpreter
trans literator School nurses and any
other individuals credential by the
state board RSA
21n a d defines educator as educator
means a teacher or
certified prayer
professional
period and then I'm going on and reading
RSA 18914 a Roman 5 States teacher means
any professional employee of any school
district whose position requires
certification as a professional engaged
in
teaching so and and it goes on says the
term teacher shall also include
principles assist assistant principles
Librarians and guidance
counselors so just to come in so I think
what you've actually just pointed out is
that there are the the legislative uh
record is not all that clean and easy to
understand um again I do believe that uh
you know we you know coming out of our
first y car meeting that the term
educator will just reflect exactly what
is in statute um part of the reason why
we had a broader definition is because
we use the term broadly um so for
example if you were to turn over to
ed360 you know policy development is
individuals responsible for
superintendent services or the sh keep
students parents and Educators is what
we had originally proposed um because it
was a broad definition so now what
you'll probably see if we change the
definition of Educators that will'll
have to change there because we don't
want the super intend is to just let the
teachers and the pair of professionals
know about the uh the policies we want
everybody to know about it so it will
really be expanded to really school and
District Personnel more broadly so again
try to be efficient um but if there's a
statutary definition of educator we
certainly want to use that and use it
correctly yeah and there's also
reference to educator definition in the
code of conduct code of ethics which
references a section law I couldn't
find any rate um so take this issue of
educator versus teacher and all that
then I went to the section which is
dealing with
the um ratio in the classroom size Etc
I'm trying to find out that section
right here
now
yeah 30614 where it says the joint
legislative committee wa minute educator
ratios um when we develop the costing
for an adequate education we we didn't
use this term student educator ratio we
used the term student teacher
ratio
um and we set up the class sizes you
know K through two
25:1 and the rule says hopefully we can
get that down to 20 to1 and then grades
three
through 12 30 to1 um when when we get
the definition there of student student
educator ratios vers student teacher
ratios which are licensed and
certified are we opening this up to more
than just the certified teacher yeah so
I think that and so this is a question
that was raised at jelar as well and I'm
happy to kind of address it we think
that the framework that we had
established already required that but
part of the definition update for
educator will make sure that it's very
clear but if you turn back act to
30612 to carry out the educational
program The Local School Board shall
require that each school provides and
under three for the hiring training of
Educators as defined now in uh as a uh
you know in in 21n of Educators licensed
under ed500 to facilitate learning to
their credential content area or as
assigned by the superintendent and so
some have said well because that
definition of educator includes a
teacher and a paraprofessional our
school board's going to be able to put a
paraprofessional in charge of the math
class but in fact if you read this it
says they have to be licensed in the
content area so that is not we don't
believe that that is permissible under
this rule as it is constructed you can't
just stick anybody because they're a
quote unquote educator other than minor
assignments into those roles and so we
do think that it is a system uh that is
cohesive and osed in the sense of the uh
the the concern that has been raised we
don't you know again and and we think
we've gone even beyond that we didn't
think we had to change the definition of
educator other than match the statute we
think that before it was a cohesive
enclosed system but by changing the
definition of educator it even makes it
more clear that this is a closed and
cohesive system that requires as three
states that we have Educators that are
licensed under ed500 for the learning
that takes place in that Ed educational
program see in in 21n col 8D which we've
referenced already today y it doesn't
say just par professional it says
certified PA professional certified par
profession but they would have to be
certified right so it does you could not
only could you not put just any par
professional would have to be a
certified but par professionals are not
certified to car to facilitate the
learning in a credential content area
like what is the remember if you look at
30612 A3
uh it says that they hold the Educators
licensed under ed500 to facilitate
learning in their credentialed content
area I could not sit here today and tell
you what the credentialed content area
of a paraprofessional is right like it
would not be any of the content areas
that we've just reviewed so I I that's
why I think that this is again a
cohesive and a closed system so looking
at the definition of educator that we
have proposed in rule here vers and also
when we come down this ratio area does
there have to be more of a tie in and so
is there confusion here now as to when
we're talking about the pupil educator
ratio
um are we including non-certified people
in that ratio we're not because if you
in that credential content area right
you can't just stick anybody in there
just because you want to we don't
believe that's our understanding of how
this is
developed and I think I'm being very
clear about that because I know that
there are Skeptics of that but I think
that that those words are very specific
and very
clear it's confusing play I I was I was
looking at the code of ethics a code of
conduct and defines Educators any
professional employee of any school
district whose position requires
certification by the State Board of
Education pursuant to RSA
18939 um that speaks to administrator
Specialists and
teachers and that that's so that's a
different Rule and it has a different
context the little green book yeah it's
educator misconduct and and so I'm not
sure so that needs to be updated because
we updated the rues yeah U well maybe
not so um that definition is used in the
cont context of misconduct we would not
want to use a 21n definition in that
because it's not uncommon for us to have
educator misconduct actions against
administrators against superintendents
or something right and so we want to
make sure that they that code of conduct
applies to them and not just to teachers
and certified par professionals but I
mean that's a separate issue that I'm
happy to take up separately but that
definition is not cond this definition
if somebody's not behaving well they
lose their ticket they lose their
certification well it depends on what
happens but that's the outcome you can
have in the various categories there but
in dealing with this I'm concerned with
the pupil teacher
ratio we appreciate that we've heard
feedback on that we we think that we've
we don't believe that it's a problem uh
we have updated the definition and made
the respective changes to be able to
make sure that that's quite clear of
what the requirements are uh so when we
went the inputs back in 2008 in
the commission or the committee for the
joint legislative committee for the
development of costing of an adequate
education we have it very specifically
defined in that and that's how we're
basing our funding formula right now off
that unless it somehow changes from that
end the table um that it
specifies pupil teacher ratio for class
size and so I I don't want to get into a
situation here where we're putting in
non-licensed people as part of this
education ratio and our ratio is really
not what we need in order to accomplish
the job of a certified staff member in
the classroom understand and I'm happy
to take this back because as you know
that there are several litigations that
are taking place with respect to that um
I do believe the that the Department of
Justice has taken a look at this
language but I'm happy to bring that
good I'm just scanning through some of
my yellow marks and I just I guess I
also just want to put on the record
clearly that uh well the the legisl did
a variety of different analyses with
respect to the cost of an adequate
education um you know that how that
amount is determined as a legislative
you know issue not one for the
Department
there's another
area when we're looking at Career
Technical
education um page is that page 13 Ed
30616 and I think I don't have numbers
on I'm dealing with I got initially from
Jen
um let me go back and find another so
30616 CTE programs do you know what page
with page 30 the side by side
see this is under policy
development that's that would be
somewhere else that's over in 306.000 I
believe so that's right it's going back
to 306.000 4 policy development okay and
got a lot of
policies 21 basic learning
standards okay
include how students can pursue various
learning opportunities
including um it talks about dual
concurrent enrollment and Career
Technical education and
certification um for some
reason I hit I I have RSA 188 e colon 25
as yell out there I'm trying to figure
out going back see number three go back
reference and but the one right below it
too it says uh dual and concurrent
enrollment in college courses
that's also in high
school concurrent is high
school taught by High School staff yes
so we were just referring to the fact
that duel and concurrent are when a
student is receiving postsecondary
Credit in their high schools or they're
accessing those post-secondary courses
directly so you have both dual as well
as the concurrent and and to your point
the concurrent is relative to earning
those College it's a college it becomes
a college course at that point so they
earn high school credit as well as
postsecondary
credit and again this is a section in
the section we're just asking that the
schools Define a policy for how those
facilities it says the local school
board shall require that the facilities
operated by the school district for K
through
12 then when I go down and look
at
30610 we talk about prek through
12 so in one case we're calling it K12
another place we're calling it prek
through 12 so I can go check and see
what if because we're referencing the Ed
320 rules and so we have to determine if
the Ed 320 rules would incorporate the
PRK or not um but if that's if if it
needs to be prek P like pre PK to 12
then we can uh you know work on that as
well I think that's potenti do you have
a question on well I was just going to
say in Ed 3610 is what you're referring
to food and
nutrition with the p prek i I believe
that specifically because of referencing
nutrition and all that it has to include
the preschool and um so that's why
that's there in that section because if
they do have preschool they have to be
included in that for the food and
nutrition and some of that's driven by
USDA regulations like if they're running
a prek opportunity and they have a
certain amount of time they're required
to offer a meal or a snack time over a
time K8
30610 is where I went next um it says
for the purpose of this rule students
under jurisdiction of a school shall
include all students enrolled in
preschool or kindergarten within a
building controlled by the school
district what's the definition of
controlled um so I think the we're
referring there is that we do have some
schools who have uh prek programs that
are uh you know the build it might be a
separate building and it might even be
operated under a contract for the school
so we want to make sure that we're not
excluding
that and we're basically trying to tell
them that they still have some
does the word controlled really say what
you just said
uh cont okay and again there's a lot of
configurations for those programs they
don't always look the same so yeah I
know
it and there was one area in Sciences
where where we had lab sciences and we
had a rule before due to safety that we
didn't want any labs having more than 24
to one in it and that part was taken out
of rule do you know why that was taken
out um so that essentially and we looked
at that through a CTE lens as well as
far as like lab um so there's going to
be building standards in terms of the
station so rather than specifying the
number of students the safety
requirements were
to only have as many students as there
were stations in order of safety so
those numbers are still going to be the
same based on how those stations were
built out um well the old rule had that
in it
too it it did said you had have the
facility available to teach the kids
which are in that but they also are
saying that the supervision I I'm I'm
now this is what I'm interpreting from
it that the teacher that has to respon
ability for a
it I mean this is hold
on that was I I can go back and take a
look at that I think that that is in the
320s now I'd have to ask Amy to that
yeah it says right here in no cases
shall the number of students in
laboratory classes exceed 24 that's in
current rule that's not in the change
that you have that's in the existing
rule that's an existing rule yes yeah so
I'd have to go see what we carried over
to 320 but I do know that one of the
issues as Amy was trying to work towards
is that we have some schools that have
larger lab spaces and trying to make
sure that we accommodate those as well
so I'm not sure what she's done relative
okay okay the last one I had well not I
don't know if this the last yellow Mark
30619 oh
it has a c underneath there I don't have
the page number I apologize for
that it says CTE Cooperative agreements
shall require the sending and receiving
school districts to coordinate calendars
and schedules to maximize students
access to CTE program pursuant 2 Ed
1304 we now have which we put in the law
several years ago and we're nearing the
point where they they got to comply with
that a regional Career Technical
education agreements shall require the
sending the receiving school districts
to coordinate calendars and schedule to
maximize student access to CTE programs
pursuant
to 134.0 2 and in compliance with RSA
1881 a Roman 3 should we not put in that
we have that in law right now where you
can only you we don't want them having
more than 10 non-aligned days so so we
can do that I I do believe that the
statute's referenced in the
13042 and does that that does that have
this language that we have in statute
yes that rule is much more specific and
detailed as to the actual Regional CTE
agreements we brought those rules
forward last year when the law came into
effect so that law has been incorporated
into those
rules like the change that you made yeah
and then we're just referencing to Rule
and the commissioner can give waivers
for about another year and then there's
no more
waivers and we'll be asking where are we
on this how many waivers did I grant no
not how many waivers how many are out of
compliance because in another year they
won't be in
compliance well I mean actually I I'm
I'm hoping and I know that there's a you
know a lot of emphasis placed on the
importance of making sure that we are
homogenizing calendars and schedule so
that students can get access to the
programming I mean I think as you know
that that's a priority of
mine yeah I think it's very much a
priority of mine as well um see I'm help
write that law um so that's all I have
repr luno thank you Mr chair on the
subject of CTE do um do all the CTE
programs that are offered throughout the
state today um have a third- party um uh
assessment
um so it depends on the area so when you
say I'm not sure I know what you're
talking about yeah so talking about for
certificates well because it's really
based on program not the whole I'm
actually I'm actually talking about
30616 and the proposed rules yeah and
G4 so G is an approved CT program shall
be one that colon and four is implements
thirdparty assessments as recognized and
designated by the department yeah so I
don't know the answer of every because I
know that there are many assessments and
they're generally tied to the industry
recognized credentials at the students
earning but I couldn't sit here to today
and tell you that so they are
implementing thirdparty assessments
absolutely whether every single program
has an assessment or not I don't know
the answer okay because that's a change
and and one of the other um changes as
well is in the in the back half of the
rules in um
get
uh in current rule
30634 which has been um which is being
repealed right because we've moved much
of that content to the front side right
there something that we didn't move
forward that you're concern well just
one one area that sort of jumps out at
me is the um is the list of um of about
I don't know 16 17 different areas um uh
nationally recognized Career Cluster
areas that I think our CTE programs
focus on right now and and I agree you
know these can change over time and
maybe we're being too prescriptive
having them in rules but um but you know
these These are areas that I think uh
are
are of you know you know
likely to have you know
interest in the legislature because they
um you know there are areas that that
provide um skills for a student coming
you know while they're in high school
while they come out of high school where
they can uh enter certain certain fields
and provide useful you know valuable you
know skills having come out of the CTE
program so so um I'm just wondering why
those were were eliminated so I mean to
your point I mean so we do Center all of
the programming around the uh the
industry cluster areas we've got you
know our industry advisory boards who
are weighing in on those um but to your
point uh it's somewhat of a dynamic um
you know list in the sense that things
change and so uh it's you know we think
we can work very closely with the CTE
centers to make sure that we're offering
and approving relevant programs for the
students to be able to access um I can
tell you that we had seen in the past
some of our programs become stale um I'm
happy to you know an example of that you
know many of the programs going back you
know a number of years I think we pretty
much have moved Beyond this at this
point in time offered what we're often
referred to as marketing programs to
students um but when you looked at the
marketing program it was really more of
a retail program and they were uh you
know operating a display case and
arranging you know School sweatshirts
and stuff like that and so we encourage
the schools to move forward and
marketing to be much more of a you know
Amazon type of a of a program like this
says to be digital and how do you access
millions of people and stuff like that
uh another example is we had a number of
uh Horticultural programs or we had some
Horticultural programs where um and I
love it you know students were working
on you know growing orchids and doing
Orchid arrangements and stuff like that
you know good skill fun to have not
going to be your high- wage job but
plant science is the emergence out of
that and we see a lot of investment here
in the state and in across New England
in terms of PL science so um really I
think that the logic is probably uh just
to make sure that we can continue to
have a system that's responsive to the
needs of our Industries yeah I think
that's I think it's fair enough I with
respect to PL science I think you know
that's probably covered in some of the
um some of the uh cluster areas that
you've that are in existing rules too
because you've got agriculture is
certainly uh one of those areas um but
um but you know thanks I think that that
answers the
question are there any other questions
from the committee regarding the the
side looks like we've asked our our
questions thank you well thank you very
much for coming forward today and
helping
you now for the committee here
we are we are tasked with the
responsibility of making some
here
uh to make recommendation review and
make
recommendations uh uh to academic
standards under consideration by the
state board and minimum standard Public
School approval under consideration by
the State Board of Education pursuant to
the state board has approved these right
now
so uh attorney moral can you help us out
with this do we we we
can't are we in a position right now
where we make our recommendations
according to what we're supposed to be
doing here to the State Board they've
approved so do our recommendations go
forth to jard
um I'm afraid I can't answer that uh for
the record Mike Michael moral uh
director of administrative rules within
OS uh the statute doesn't seem to say
who the recommendation is made to uh it
seems like it would be beneficial if it
went both to the department and to jail
car okay chairman if I'm I mean we're
happy to take any recommendations
whether the front half or the back half
as both of these evolve and that any
point in time we can bring those back to
the State Board of Education for
reconsideration so so we're interested
feedback so uh
commissioner you've approved these have
approved board but if something happens
at Jael car we got bring it back then
you're going to go through
yeah okay I could I could go over that
process a a little bit Yeah would you
please uh last month Department brought
forward the Jael car the first half what
they brought was their final proposal my
staff had commented on the final
proposal and based on those comments and
probably public testimony the department
said okay we want to address some of
those issues so they put forth a
conditional approval request uh which is
what jel car looked at and took
testimony on um but Jael car decided at
last month's meeting that they really
needed both halves taken up at the same
time uh because they were so
interchangeable and each side affected
the other um next month jokar will be
taking up both with the uh second half
it will be the final proposal um we have
not my office has not yet received that
and reviewed it once we do we'll send
that to the department and they may put
that and just to be clear we were
waiting we were waiting until we heard
back from you all before we submitted
the final for them to take a look at we
went okay so that lets us know where we
are right now in the process the process
and that's not the final end of the
process I mean if the conditional
approval still didn't take care of
everything and were further things that
department wanted to correct then they
could do an amended conditional approval
uh Jael car can approve the final
proposals and conditional approvals or
they can do a preliminary objection if
they do a preliminary objection then the
department has a deadline to come back
with a new text um to the degree that
they do not make changes which they're
not required to do they will lay those
out in a letter explaining why they feel
that the that issue is not one they
should uh
change thank
you further information needed from the
committee thank you very
retiring after next month's
wow I I think you got to talk to your
wife
first okay
um I I think what we need to do is the
committee needs a little opportunity we
we want to talk about some because if
we're going to make some recommendations
for your consideration at the department
we got got to do that quickly here we
also have a date set for next
Monday um if we need
it to to um to do this
so I I'm putting out to committee
members right now do you want to sit
here and try to Wade through and try to
whittle this thing down and where we are
up or down now or do you want to have
sort of work session and then come back
and make a decision uh perhaps on Monday
the
21st well M Mr chair thanks um for
putting that out there I'd still like to
hear back from the commissioner with
respect to the connection between the
current rules and the um uh curriculum
Frameworks or academic standards as
they've been referred to because the
clearly the proposed rules have that
connection in place the Incorporated
reference but I just would you know want
to understand where that is in the
current
rules I think the Commissioners agreed
that any comments from the committee on
that yes represent in in the current
rules I'm not sure where the reference
is to the Frameworks not not in the 36s
I don't see that for instance math in
36s the current 36s I don't see any
reference to that I'm I'm not either
right but but I think also if you look
at the um uh definition of rules and in
21 uh and N um it talks about rules
relative to the minimum standard so I
don't think that it lays out a direct
connection that the rules are in any way
themselves well I think we have said
through statutory language last year
that the rules are not the academic
standards right but but if a if a major
part of these changes is now
incorporating the academic standards
through reference where those had not
been Incorporated through reference in
the past then then that's a pretty
substantial change um you know because
that's the difference
between making it a requirement for
school approval and um and not having it
approval the meeting on monday1 o' the
meeting on
morning have some things on Monday is
that scheduled well yes that's in the
calendar and then you have a one o'clock
EFA meeting yes yeah 9:30
yeah we
do yes that's but yeah I would just say
that um the current math uh rule does
not refer to common core standards but I
think it's um pretty well understood
that the Common Core math standards are
the state
standards even though that it doesn't
program one of the
points last yel car meeting had to
do one of the points that was discussed
at the last jail car meeting was the
class I
some people had a very
you they felt the class size was just
too big and I have heard since then
people mistakenly saying that there's
absolutely no control over the class
size they can go up to 50 kits and this
is what's being touted so I think that
has to be dealt
with then the class sizes this it as
25 or less
and nobody's paying attention to that
for for K through
2 it's
25 or less and recommend 20 yes and for
three through 12 it's
30 and recommended 25 or try to hold it
to
25 um there was an attempt last year
when we were dealing with the budget
side of things and we were looking at
the inputs to the
formula to try and set it up so it would
be K through grade three with that
lesser ratio of
25 seeing the middle schools start at
grade four and go forward um the grade
schools basically go through grade some
go through grade six yes but the statory
language also says you know four through
eight can be a middle school so we we
looked at that um and it didn't
fly but I think that's something that's
got to be done and I don't know if it
should be done through this rul making
process or if it should be done
statutorily when we're talking about
finances and inputs vers
outcomes and I'm sure that discussion is
coming up again this year it
will so
um but I agree with you you know the the
the actual what what is the act ual
enroll and ratio is at right around 12
to1 in the elementary schools 12.7
12.7 May a little yeah
yeah okay so do you want to try to take
a break and finish this out today or do
you want to come back on Monday I have
an appointment at 1 so you okay we'll
have to come back
yeah we'll come back yeah yeah 9:30
Monday morning okay and the purpose of
that would be then to come up with our
as we're required
the recommendations related to these
academic or minimum standards of public
school approval and both and those
recommendations could include
changes to what we've been presed today
yeah I'm
sure we can
recom yeah yeah okay
so that's what we'll do then we'll come
back and take that up on
Monday is there anything else for the
docket
today not seeing anybody saying yes so
what we're going to do is close this
meeting down and we will just a letter
from you all with some recommendations
thank you yeah and it'll be done before
November thank you very much for coming
today